[Musique]
il
moi
il ya un peu plus d'un an le 4 juillet
2015 les coteaux maisons et caves de
champagne ainsi que les climats de
bourgogne étaient classés au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco avec les vignes de
saint-émilion dans le bordelais inscrite
elle en 1999
ce sont trois des plus grandes régions
viticoles françaises qui ont été honorés
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui dans le
prestigieux château d'yquem considéré
comme le plus grand vin liquoreux au
monde
yquem voilà un nom qui fait rêver tout
comme petrus et margot ses voisins
bordelais romanée conti le roi clos de
vougeot pour le vignoble de bourgogne ou
encore croque veuve clicquot salon pour
la champagne aujourd'hui c'est leur
histoire que nous avons décidé de vous
raconter une histoire dans laquelle
s'entremêlent d aventure humaine
exceptionnelle à savoir faire ancestral
un art de vivre à la française un
patrimoine architectural hors du commun
car derrière ces étiquettes et ses
nectars de légende se cachent des
trésors uniques au monde fruit de notre
culture et de notre histoire
[Musique]
ces trésors
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui les cultivent et les préserve
grâce à eux nous avons découvert un
patrimoine viticole aussi riche que
magique
elles font rayonner la france à
l'étranger depuis des siècles les
maisons de champagne les plus
prestigieuses nous ont ouvert leurs
portes mais aussi des livres et leurs
secrets il n'y a pas un autre domaine
dans le monde à une autre propriété à
notre chaton qui n'a produit que 37 fois
du vin en 100 ans à plusieurs dizaines
de mètres sous terre
nous avons eu rendez vous avec la grande
histoire et découvert de véritables
chefs-d'oeuvre
a bordeaux nous avons exhumé le
classement original des grands vins du
médoc de 1855 et eu le privilège de
visiter tous les premiers crus classés
[Musique]
pour la première fois des caméras de
télévision étaient autorisés à pénétrer
au coeur du mythique est vénéré domaine
de pomerol pétrus je pense que chaque
sensibilité c'est la qualité la plus
importante que j'ai peut-être transmis à
mes fils
nous avons aussi rencontré michel jack
le propriétaire attachant d'un
patrimoine vertigineux une collection de
quarante mille flacons d'exception
il est vrai que là vous avez ici la
vitre de ma famille
[Musique]
dans les coins et recoins du légendaire
château du clos de vougeot
nous avons effectué un véritable voyage
dans le temps tout à l'heure je parlais
de magie et bien nous y sommes en plein
dans la magie puisque nous sommes devant
le pressoir construit en 1477
[Musique]
enfin nous participerons avec les
artisans du château d'yquem à
l'élaboration très particulière du plus
illustre des vins liquoreux
[Musique]
première halte dans un lieu aussi
symbolique que prestigieux le palais de
l'elysée
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré virginie roux this
la première sommelière de la résidence
du chef de l'état elle nous a ouvert
exceptionnellement les portes d'une des
caves les plus secrètes et les plus
renommés au monde qui conserve pas moins
de douze mille bouteilles
[Musique]
un peu de personnes ont accès à la cave
c'est l'intendant et moi même d'après un
front dans la cas d'élise et ben on peut
sans voix je connaissais bien sûr les
grandes étiquettes sont les plus belles
étiquettes les plus beaux flacons oui
sommeil perso de bouteilles cela vous
est la plus vieille de la cale sèche à
tori 1 5906 on étiquette est un peu
abîmée mais mon prédécesseur a réussi un
à celles ci n'ont normalement ne sera
pas ouvert mise à part s'il ya une
demande du président de la république
lui seul que deux de ces bouteilles là
où est en effet la seule personne qui
peut exiger dans l'ouverture c'est nous
toutes les régions de france y sont bien
sûr représenté avec néanmoins une
domination des vins de bordeaux de
bourgogne et de champagne ce qui se
comprend quand même représenter la
france mais moi j'ai vraiment travaillé
sur les autres régions représentait la
france c'est l'une des missions de
virginie lors des dîners officiels ses
meilleurs ambassadeurs
ce sont ces bouteilles tous les vins
blancs même sur un dîner d'état on va
ouvrir énormément de vin tous les vins
sont goûtés ont choisi le vin en
fonction des personnalités bien sûr du
protocole sur un dîner d'état suivant
mais on peut aller autant sur un grand
bourg bonne ou à grands sauternes sur le
désaccord de notre chef et après c'est
également les quantités parce que un
dîner d'état il ya quand même trois
cents convives en général donc il faut
voir à voir
nombre de bouteilles qui suivent pour
300 combinois sortir trentaine de vins
blancs une quarantaine de vin rouge et
en champagne
pareil quarantaine parmi ses plus beaux
souvenirs
la réception à l'elysée de la reine
d'angleterre à l'occasion des 70 ans du
débarquement de normandie là vraiment
on avait servi de prêts très très beau
vin c'était château yquem jeu 97 et
après je crois qu'on était sur un
margaux on avait également pour le clin
d'oeil pour la reine servi de winston
churchill en champagne parce que voilà
c'est c'est le champagne vraiment
emblématique de la reine ce soir là
virginie avait servi des vins de légende
pour représenter la france aux yeux du
monde entier
je pense que c'est vraiment le vin c'est
emblématique et on a cette chance en
france ça va un moment
le patrimoine des forêts
ce patrimoine du vignoble français
nous l'avons arpenter à la recherche de
ses plus beaux trésors la cave de
l'elysée refermer nous avons poussé les
portes des châteaux et domaines les plus
prestigieux à commencer par ceux de la
champagne
[Musique]
on va
trente cinq mille hectares de vignes 320
village un patrimoine architectural
unique
[Musique]
des noms de légende le champagne symbole
de fête et d'amour fait rêver saliver
les papilles du monde entier
[Musique]
mais d'où vient-il
ce champagne commençons par tordre le
cou à la légende non l'illustrent don
pérignon d'un n'est pas l'inventeur
jusqu'à la fin du xviie siècle la
champagne produit des vins rouges à
partir de raisins rouges et des vins
blancs à partir de raisins blancs mais
de piètre qualité
alors pour satisfaire et élargir leur
clientèle quelque champenois visionnaire
et ingénieux dont l'abbé don pérignon
conçoivent un vin totalement inédit et
de grande qualité
il assemble plusieurs raisins issus de
différents cépages de différents crus et
de différentes années il affine sa
vinification pour maîtriser
l'effervescence naturel ils se
fournissent en flacon mieux adaptée à la
prise de mousse et fabrique des bouchons
hermétique
bref il invente un vin nouveau qui va
devenir l'un des fleurons les plus
éclatants de la france à l'étranger
nous avons eu le privilège de pénétrer
dans l'une des maisons de champagne les
plus luxueuses mais aussi les plus
secrètes de reims la maison krug
krook quatre lettres mythiques 1,20
considérée comme la rolls royce du
champagne
un vin qui année après année à la
singularité d'être identique à celui
imaginé par le fondateur de la maison il
y à plus de 170 ans
l'une de ses artisans
c'est julie cavill ancien publicitaire
elle a tout quitté il y a quinze ans
pour accomplir son rêve devenir
oenologue maison groupe s'était c'était
quelque chose d'un peu inaccessible pour
en plus quelqu'un qui appartient à
l'analogie c'était vraiment le graal
travaillé chez kruger
j'avais cette image de qualité sans
compromis
retour au regarde les notes qui sont
attribués depuis 20 ans c'est toujours
des notes extraordinaire extraordinaire
et en moins je me disais ça y est c'est
incroyable ça fait quatre ans que je
rêve de ça j'avais même pas imaginer que
ça puisse se passer ici j'y suis
[Musique]
oenologue depuis maintenant 10 ans pas
un des recoins de la maison cook n'a de
secret pour elle julie nous invite à
découvrir la chambre forte
nous voici la de la maison le cuvier des
vins de réserve
[Musique]
alors ici on a tout ce qui fait
l'individualité de la maison on est dans
un lieu vraiment d'exception qui pour
nous est vraiment notre trésor pour
l'équipe nologie puisque ici vous voyez
que on a des petits contenants qui ont
été réalisés sur mesure pour épouser
parfaitement la forme de la voûte et
nous conservons les vins issus de 15 16
annette vendanges différentes donc un
vin il peut rester ici dans cette
bibliothèque finalement de vins de
réserve une année deux ans 5 ans 10 ans
15 ans ce sont ces précieux vins de
réserve
associé aux vins issus de l'année en
cours qui permettront de retrouver le
goût authentique déterminé par le
fondateur joseph krogans 10 843
il est 11 heures l'heure pour julie de
déguster tous ces vins qui une fois
choisi assemblée élaboreront le
champagne grandes cuvées tiens voilà
georges va georges
honnêtement ce qui m'a frappé quand je
suis arrivé à la maison c'est le nombre
de métiers de gestes de personnes qui
sont nécessaires pour élaborer nos
cuvées chez krogan il ya ceux qui sont
experts des fûts ce qui les visitent ce
qui les sentent ce qui les en tonnes ce
qui les marques au pochoir ce qui les
arrange traditionnellement avec des
cales qui a un savoir-faire qui prend
plus d'une année et tous ces personnes
la touche pas forcément le 20 mai sont
totalement indispensable pour réaliser
élaborer nos curés exceptionnellement
julie nous a autorisés à assister à ce
comité de dégustation étape cruciale
avant l'assemblage
alors voilà c'est aussi là que ça se
passe
comme tous les jours à 11 heures le
comité de dégustation de la maison
crooks se réunit ici pour déguster 15
échantillons
alors vous et mieux c'est notre part
celle qu'ont à l'entrée du
mesnil-sur-oger au total julie et le
comité devront choisir parmi les 150
vins de réserve et les 220 issus de
l'année en cours pour recréer le goût
originel
khroub où ces vins et en déguster deux à
trois fois vous faites le calcul
plus le nombre de dégustateurs autour de
la table en général on traite à peu près
4000 notes de dégustation pour arriver à
l'assemblage de la grande que la grande
cuvée elle est recréé toujours avec dix
onze douze treize années de vendanges
différentes entre 150 et 200 parcelles
différentes et on dit qu'il faut à peu
près 20 ans pour élaborer une seule
bouteille de chrome en recul
vingt ans pour élaborer une seule
bouteille entre 150 et 200 vins
différents en un seul flacon une
patience et une exigence qui justifie le
caractère et le prix unique de ce
champagne
[Musique]
c'est éric lebel le chef de cave qui
dirige comme tous les jours la séance
aujourd'hui sont présents les membres du
pôle oenologie mais aussi les dirigeants
de la maison olivier khroub et margareth
henriquez voilà donc tout le monde est
prêt les ipads sont calés c'est parti
c'est bon quelle note humeur que je m
14la julie mais je vais être plus
généreuses les mettre un bon 16 je
trouve qu'il a une élégance une finesse
un port de tête il erra c'est donc dans
l'assemblage ça va vraiment élevé relevé
le monde
chardonnay ses notes de dégustation
julie les sauvegardes sur sa tablette
eric quant à lui les conservent toujours
dans son grand livre noir il en possède
des dizaines et perpétue ainsi la
tradition du fondateur joseph qu il
serait content je pense devoir notebook
jose affiche très content de voir que
cette notion d'individualités elle
perdure toujours et que la maison existe
encore qu'à travers sa mêlée très
longtemps devant la version digitale
ouais c'est sûr aussi long
olivier khroub sixième génération de la
famille gardien de la maison nous
entraîne dans un salon privé qui abrite
le livre originel de joseph crone un
précieux carnet conservé dans son écrin
à la fin des années 70 mon grand père a
retrouvé ce carnet qui avait été rangé
dans un coffre par son propre grand-père
presque un siècle plus tôt
et quand je suis rentré dans la maison
en 89 c'est une des premières choses
dont il m'a parlé et m'a dit écoute
olivier un jour il faudra que tu lises
ce carnet et j'ai mis 25 ans à réouvrir
ce carnet et on a fait l'exercice
collectivement il ya six ou sept ans et
on est on est tous tombés de notre
chaise est le premier à être surpris
c'était peut-être éric lebel le chef de
cave parce que quand on lit ce carnet en
commun il découvre de façon très claire
très précise les gestes lui fais tous
les jours qu'il a appris de mon papa des
anciens etc
cent soixante dix ans plus tard il est
clair que cros correspond rêve que
joseph avait en tête quand il a tout
quitté à l'âge de 42 ans pour créer un
type de champagne qui n'existaient pas
le véritable trésor de la maison il est
probablement là dans cette transmission
cet échange entre les générations et les
métiers
aujourd'hui julie en est l'une des plus
authentiques héritière voyez ici vous
avez des années et des années de
vendanges l'idée est de transmettre
justement ça aux futures générations
donc on est là au milieu il faut rester
très très avec beaucoup aux faux faut
avoir beaucoup d'humilité à l'oenologie
puisqu'on est vraiment c'est passeurs ce
témoin entre ce devoir de mémoire
du patrimoine de la maison et puis ceux
de voir aussi de transmission pour les
futures générations
dénicher ces trésors du vignoble de
champagne c'est aller à la rencontre de
passionnés de véritables artisans d'art
qui mettent leur savoir faire et leur
excellence au service de notre
patrimoine culturel
mais c'est aussi voyager à travers les
siècles et les continents
[Musique]
son nom évoque un certain art de vivre à
la française
il est le deuxième champagne le plus
vendu dans le monde et illumine depuis
bientôt deux cent cinquante ans les
réceptions les plus fastueuses le
champagne veuve clicquot nous avons pu
accéder aux arcanes de la maison pour
découvrir comment ce champagne a
représenté la france aux quatre coins de
la planète pendant plus de deux siècles
fabienne moreau en charge du patrimoine
de la maison nous a ouvert les portes
des archives
on est dans un lieu exceptionnel puisque
cela qu'on conserve l'ensemble des
archives de la maison veuve clicquot
depuis la date de la fondation en 1772
jusqu'à 1950 à peu près c'est en
exhumant ses archives rares que nous
avons découvert le destin de celle qui
est à l'origine de ce succès
barbe-nicole ponsardin une bourgeoise de
reims devenue veuve a 27 ans et qui va
avoir l'audace de reprendre les rênes de
la maison familiale fondée par son beau
père philippe clicquot on né en 1805
on est pendant une période extrêmement
troublé en europe sont les guerres
napoléoniennes les récoltes n'ont pas
été extraordinaires du tout dans les
années qui précèdent et là on découvre
un personnage extraordinaire de
détermination d'intelligence de vision
parce que on est à une époque où le
champagne c'est encore un produit un peu
expérimentale ensuite elle va vraiment
s'attacher à la qualité des vins à
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe et
on lui doit des progrès vraiment
significatif en termes d'élaboration du
champagne que l'on utilise toujours
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui invente la
technique de remuage des bouteilles sur
une table puis sur des pupitres et c'est
un moment décisif pour la champagne
et ensuite et c'est très important
elle va est faire preuve d'une grande
ténacité pour exporter ses vins
la france est un marché extrêmement
restreint le champagne est déjà un
produit de luxe difficiles à élaborer il
coûte cher
la première femme à diriger une maison
de champagne décide alors d'élargir ses
horizons de vente
première escale la russie on a une vraie
francophilie chez les couches chez les
consommateurs les amateurs russe et la
consommation de champagne va avec
l'amour des belles lettres françaises
avec les plaisir d'avoir des beaux
objets des beaux tableaux venant de
france
la littérature etc donc c'est un tout un
art de vivre qui s'exporte à travers une
bouteille de champagne
de l'europe du sud à la russie en
passant même par la laponie
son champagne conquiert dès le 19e
siècle le monde entier femme moderne et
déterminée la veuve clicquot n'a qu'un
objectif participer à la grandeur de la
france
nous avons un document exceptionnel
c'est vraiment une pépite dans notre
trésor des archives
il s'agit d'un document plus personnel
donc sur lequel tu écris le nom de
madame picot ne l'avions pas dans nos
archives c'est une personne qui l'a
trouvée dans un grenier d'un un château
qu'il venait d'acheter
nelly encore vraiment son activité au
sein du vignoble d'achat de raisin de
négoce de produits liés à la vigne et
puis c'est vrai que je vous disais qu'il
y avait beaucoup d'émotion parce que
nous on est là sur la date d'avril 1866
et donc on est quelques mois avant sa
disparition
on a là certainement les derniers écrits
de même un petit caux
dame de fer la veuve clicquot n'en
restait pas moins une dame de coeur
humaniste elle fonda des écoles une
maison de retraite et dans son château
de bourse au près d'epernay elle créera
une caisse de secours
un château dans lequel elle s'éteindra à
89 ans
[Musique]
la maison de champagne perpétuera ses
valeurs tout au long du xxème siècle
fabienne moreau nous invite à les
découvrir dans un endroit tout à fait
mystérieux à plusieurs dizaines de
mètres sous terre
[Musique]
si on se trouve dans l'écrit hier de la
maison veuve clicquot
c'est un endroit emblématique pour
l'histoire de grâce pour l'histoire du
champagne pour l'histoire de la maison
parce que on y trouve vraiment les
éléments liés au patrimoine donc les
premières crièrent ont été creusés à
l'époque gallo romaine à reims les blocs
de craie été extrait pour pouvoir
construire les remparts qui fortifier la
ville selmon se trouve aujourd'hui
eh bien ils sont plus du moyen-âge du
11ème 12ème siècle et l on était donc
abandonné à une fois la carrière creusée
et c'est seulement au 19e siècle et au
début du 20e siècle pour la maison veuve
clicquot que on a réinvesti les lieux
les crayères de la butte saint-nicaise
avec leur obscurité leur tranquillité et
leur température constante de 11° sont
un endroit idéal pour la maturation du
champagne
ce sont donc des milliers d'employés qui
vont travailler dans ces 24 kilomètres
de galeries comme en témoignent ses
insolites plaque patronymique
en fait c'est vraiment un hommage rendu
à la finalité de ces personnes de la
maison donc la plaque porte le nom de ce
salarié de sa date d'entrée sa date de
sortie dans la maison et le dernier
métier qu'il a exercé parce que
généralement un jeune peut rentrer à 14
ans et est terminé sa carrière comme
chef d'atelier chef bouchonniers rhône
humeur
[Musique]
mais en 1914 la ville de reims et
bombardé aux côtés de civils et de
soldats ses employés se retrouvent un
véritable carrefour de l'histoire de
france
on est face à des traces de l'histoire
de l'histoire de la grande guerre on y
voit là une croix rouge avec une flèche
ça c'est des traces de peinture qui date
du début de la première guerre mondiale
et qui permettait donc aux personnes qui
arrivaient dans les cas de s'orienter
pour aller soit vers l'infirmerie soit
s'abriter puisqu'ici on lit aussi on
devine les lettres qui forment le mot
avery
des noms des dates de naissance
la grande guerre écrira aussi une page
de son histoire douloureuse dans
s'écrièrent de champagne
et c'est une vraie émotion de pouvoir
aussi conserver les traces de cette
histoire quand on traverse s'écrièrent
eh bien on sent en effet que rooney face
à un patrimoine qui dépasse les
videmment la ville de reims véritable
cathédrale souterraine les crayères de
la butte saint-nicaise abrite de
multiples trésors de notre histoire
sous l'impulsion d'une autre grande dame
de la champagne le vin se fait alors
oeuvres d'art à quelques centaines de
mètres des crayères de la maison veuve
clicquot luis pommery architectes du vin
et des pierres transforme à la fin du
19e siècle ces 18 km de galerie en
galerie d'art
[Musique]
en plein coeur du village du
mesnil-sur-oger une parcelle de vigne
est l'objet de toutes les attentions
cette parcelle c'est vraiment l'origine
le patrimoine de salon c'est ce qui fait
sa l'on a au début de tout avant même de
consommer les bouteilles tout par dc
c'est notre richesse
notre richesse c'est la terre cet homme
épris de cette terre c'est didier depond
tourangeau de souche il est à la tête
depuis 20 ans de la prestigieuse et très
confidentielle maison de champagne salon
salon est un champagne très discret dans
le monde du champagne on nous voit très
peu on parle très peu de nous et donc on
est également très discret sur les gens
qui consomment salon et et nos clients
mais effectivement il ya des gens très
célèbre aussi bien du cinéma du théâtre
de la musique qui sont qui sont nos
clientes salon fait partie de ces cinq
six vins divin peut-être dans le monde
qui sont recherchés par les
collectionneurs et que l'on trouve
également dans les ventes aux enchères à
des prix qui s'envolent totalement
salon est unique en champagne par son
prix aucune bouteille n'est vendu à
moins de 400 euros mais surtout par son
absence d'assemblage c'est un mono
terroir la côte des blancs un mono cru
le village du mesnil-sur-oger un mono
cépage du chardonnet un mono millésime
les vins d'une seule année aux côtés de
didier depond nous allons faire partie
des rares privilégiés à découvrir les
secrets de cette légende de la champagne
une légende créé par un homme en 1905
eugène aimé salon monsieur salon a dit
je ne vais faire du champagne qu à base
de chardonnay
c'est le créateur du blanc de blancs
chardonnay venant d'un seul crû d'un
seul village le mesnil-sur-oger là où on
se trouve aujourd'hui et je ne ferai du
champagne je ne produirai du champagne
uniquement lorsque ça sera un très grand
une très grande année à millésimé sinon
je ne ferais rien
[Musique]
il n'y a pas un autre domaine dans le
monde a eu notre propre
château dans le monde qui n'a produit
que 37 fois du vin en 100 ans
et puis pour corser encore un petit peu
la faire mais ce salon a dit je vais
garder mes vins les faire vieillir dans
la cave minimum 10 ans on peut imaginer
que si on fait un millésime 2016 il sera
disponible dans en 2030
effectivement
salon a créé le premier champagne de
garde
un champagne qui se déguste avec
parcimonie pas plus de soixante mille
bouteilles sont produites par an ils
sont donc rares ceux qui ont déjà goûté
ce champagne d'exception
aujourd'hui didier on a invité certains
déguster quelques millésimes ses amis
comme didier les appels sont indonésiens
chinois ou encore américains des amis
qui n'hésitent pas à faire des milliers
de kilomètres pour goûter une nouvelle
fois ce champagne au goût très vineux
qu'il considère unique
didier a organisé un déjeuner servi dans
un des salons de la maison
nous avons rencontré félix qui vient de
pékin il a fait plus de 8000 kilomètres
pour venir au mesnil sur oger
travailler dans la publicité mes amis
sont maîtres dans l'automobile ou dans
la musique on est
pas dans le métier du vent et on aime
tous le vin la façon de vivre à la
française
le chemin des salons ce champagne
irremplaçable par sa qualité
la recherche de la pureté voilà c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne trouve pas dans
d'autres champagne savourer de plus en
plus connus en chine
maintenant on le qualifie comme
soi-disant banni ariel quant à lui est
argentin son premier souvenir avec salon
il s'en rappelle comme si c'était hier
c'était une découverte extraordinaire et
de même les champagnes larron checker on
aimerait un produit qui fait de manière
particulière et le correctif pétition au
champagne
on les connaît on connaissait le
pionnier d'un salon aujourd'hui c'est un
résultat pas seulement des l'art est
chargé d'aider l'excellence des millions
mais c'est aussi le respect des
traditions pour veiller à déguster cias
et je crois que ça vaut la peine
n'importe quel voyage a fait la
tradition dont parle ariel nous l'avons
découverte lorsque nous avons délaissé
les hôtes de didier le temps du déjeuner
au détour d'une cave
nous avons croisé jérémy
ce jour là il était en charge du remuage
une étape qu'il réalise comme autrefois
consiste lui l'écoutaient bijoux pour
faire descendre le dépôt par gravité
beaucoup des pauvres viennent se loger
dans le goût la bouteille d'un petit
bidule en plastique qui a pris ensuite à
la fin du rembourrage sera dégorger
manuellement par jour jérémy peut remuer
jusqu'à cinquante mille bouteilles du
sport avec mes amis ça que j'ai la
chance de ma vie mais des bouteilles
c'est assez exceptionnel sont pas à la
portée de moins une image une fois
remuer jérémy devra pratiquer le
dégorgement à la volée comme autrefois
voilà l'état dégorgement donc leur nuage
était fini trois semaines que la
bouteille a été remué donc toujours le
goulot vers le bas on va placer lapin
juste deux mois la capsule
on tape un petit peu la bulle que
j'oublie pour qu'une bulle au cul de la
bouteille et là tranquillement venir
monter faire monter la bulle l'égorger
mais là on évacuer toute la bouquet dans
la bouteille et dans son truc et de
bouteilles claire
une élaboration traditionnelle et unique
qui séduit donc les amateurs bien
au-delà de nos frontières
[Musique]
l étage le repas sa chèvre combler les
invités remercie chaleureusement leur
route
ouais merci merci beaucoup
à bientôt ciao merci c'était un grand
moment un grand de partage parce que
quand on fait le les 20 que nous faisons
en fait nous les faisons pour les
partager
on a entendu le son qui monte des gens
des gens heureux des gens souriants et
des gens qui repartent avec une idée une
belle idée de la champagne une belle
idée de salon est une belle idée de la
france salon une légende méconnu devenu
pourtant l'un des fleurons du patrimoine
viticole français
[Musique]
c'est parti pour la vendange oui alors
vous francis mayer nous sommes de retour
dans les magnifiques vignes de château
d'yquem
c'est un jour vraiment très particulier
parce que ce sont les vendanges ici à
château d'yquem et ce sont des vendanges
très particulière parce que vous faites
pas à la vendange comme tout le monde si
j'ose dire vous vous attendez un petit
champignon lequel champignons s'agit
alors il s'agit d'un champignon très
commun c'est un des plus grands
ravageurs de la vigne c'est le botrytis
cinerea chez nous à sauternes peut
arriver à ce stade extraordinaire de
pourriture noble justement de raisin
confie pourquoi parce que l'on s'étant
évaporés le sucre concentré on va
arriver à un potentiel de 20 21 degrés
d'alcool et c'est le degré dont on a
besoin pour faire du sauternes alors du
coup c'est ses récoltes vous oblige
imagine avoir un rendement très faible
le moment au final extrêmement faible à
yquem on reproduit en fait un verre de
vin par pieds de vigne c'est ce grand
rôti vous aller vendanger pour vous ça
c'est la perfection absolument
sheika vous fait l'objet d'un véritable
culte quand certains sont prêts à
parcourir des milliers de kilomètres
pour venir déguster quelques centilitres
de ce précieux nectar
d'autres sont prêts à investir toutes
leurs économies pour acquérir un flacon
un souvenir une histoire
cette quête des plus beaux trésors du
vignoble français ne nous a pas conduit
uniquement dans les plus beaux châteaux
au palais de la république
à 70 kilomètres de niort en rase
campagne
michel jack chasseuil à un retraité de
75 ans je grenouille ou possède un
trésor qu aucun milliardaire au monde ne
détient fils de facteurs michel jack a
très vite été contaminé par la fièvre
collectionneuse les timbres bien sûr
puis très vite sont venues s'ajouter les
vins tout commence réellement dans les
années 60
entré chez dassault comme chaudronnier
quelques années plus tard il est chargé
d'accueillir les délégations étrangères
une mission qui lui permet de découvrir
le vin les grands vins et j'ai commencé
par acheter plus qui est elle plus rares
comme avait dit marcel dassault
des petits groupes ont cru tous les
jours mais des vins rares il vaut mieux
une bouteille d'eau en bouteille et
c'est ce que j'ai fait ce qui a permis à
ce que cette connexion comme yann unique
au monde
une collection unique au monde que
michel jack décide en l'an 2000 de
protéger
c'est ce sanctuaire qui se trouve la
source et molière pourquoi ces des
volières c'est parce que vous avez des
entrées d'aération derrière ses filets
sous ces drôles de cheminée à quelques
mètres sous terre des poulaillers se
cache l'une des plus belles caves du
monde
j'ai commandé trop nulle part paraît en
août l'an 2000 je me suis pris par la
main cinq mètres par jour
j'ai construit ma cave
et puis ça fait un blockhaus en terre de
30 mètres de long sur 5 mètres de large
[Musique]
michel jack a accepté de nous faire
découvrir son sanctuaire comme il
l'appelle
mais pour y accéder il faut s'armer de
patience et de vigilance
après avoir descendu un abrupt escaliers
éviter les pièges que michel jack qui a
placé traverser une cave ouvert une
porte blindée démonter un mur de
parpaings traverser une nouvelle ka
avait emprunté un obscur tunnel
[Musique]
nous avons pu enfin pénétrer dans le
saint des saints
là nous voici dans le sanctuaire des
vins mythiques des plus grands vins du
monde dans les plus grands millésimes
des 20 plus grands de tous les temps
[Musique]
vous avez les grands champagnes salon
les vins de la vallée du rhône là vous
avez tous les grandes
châteauneuf-du-pape château reilla henri
bonnaud ensuite nous arrivons vers la
bourgogne les monts achètent ou les tous
les marchés détestent producteurs
[Musique]
enfin si vous avez les grands vins de
bordeaux premier grand cru classé 1855
moutons margot laffite au brillant dans
les grands millésimes 61 82 90 2000 2005
2010 et j'ai par exemple un siècle 10 km
de 8900 lesca nos jours dans les plus
vieux millésime 1811 1147 1921 et la
mythique et parallèlement aux grands
blancs liquoreux tous les petrus depuis
j'ai goûté pratique beaux tous ces vins
con ça valait une bouchée de pain dans
les années 1970 au total michel jack a
rassemblé plus de 40 mille bouteilles
estimé à 40 millions d'euros
et derrière chacune de ces bouteilles
derrière chaque millésime michel jack a
une histoire à raconter
j'ai la marée bizarre du bateau titanic
est effectivement à cette époque tous
ces milliardaires était parti dans ce
bateau avec les coffres les bijoux tout
ce qu'il a de plus cher plus riches
entre eux et le soir parmi les
festivités
voilà il buvait de l'eau retient dire
que il avait pris tous leurs beaux
bijoux reflétant dans les rues sans
cristal du bateau et et avec tout ça
dans des coupes à champagne et buvait de
la barre et brisant avec des petites
paillettes d'or flou qui flottent et en
buvaient de l'eau à l'époque c'était le
raffinement suprême purificateur de sang
[Musique]
il y a aussi ce gruaud larose retrouvée
dans une épave échouée en mer de chine
en 1872 ou encore ceux petrus 1914
[Musique]
il est vrai que la punition mais vous
avez ici la vitesse de ma famille mon
grand père qui a fait la guerre 14 là
j'ai tous les écrits au rayon de papier
dans les tranchées verdun à l'excès les
jeux de ne tout de suite les militaires
il était cafetiers licence iv mon père
facteur qui paient le mandat ne prend
fin qu'en janvier en bicyclette
ils paient les mandats dans les fermes
et c'est vrai c'est peut-être grâce à
cet habit n'est pas obligatoire que je
suis là aujourd'hui en toute simplicité
humble que finalement tout est possible
sur terre si on a la volonté et pour
leur rendre hommage
j'ai donc trouvé les deux vins mythiques
rouge et blanc de france château yquem
et puis tous 1914
car mon père est né en 1914
tous les murs de la cave de michel
jackson recouvert de noms de légende
alors forcément sa collection attire la
convoitise des plus grands amateurs du
monde entier y avait un dîner de gala de
400 personnes est à côté de moi
j'aimerais chinois qui valait 1 million
d'euros par jour
alors effectivement à la fin du repas
juhasz monsieur qui se ressent aucun
effet qui me fait un chaque 50 millions
d'euros
alors j'ai dit à mon collègue monsieur
cointreau qui habite à l'époque c'est
quoi il dit monsieur ses poils à ta
collection tâche est ta collection 50
millions d'euros mais il a collectionné
pas à vendre
c'est un patrimoine est ce cas là je
connais la vendre non la collection elle
est pas de même pour 50 millions d'euros
c'est le patrimoine pour les générations
futures qui doit être conservé et qui ne
peut pas être considérée comme
collection parce que collection c'est
trop patient très privée personnelle
j'ai une collection à ce qui me concerne
c'est tu seras sans toutes ces pièces
assemblées c'est le patrimoine de
l'unesco qui appartient au monde entier
[Musique]
pour commencer un peu d'histoire si la
présence de vignes dans la région
remonte à l'antiquité
ce n'est qu'au xviiie siècle que vont
s'affirmer les grands vins de bordeaux
révolu le temps de ce vin coupé à l'eau
vendue en bariki que développait des le
xiième siècle
aliénor duchesse d'aquitaine et reine
d'angleterre au xviiie siècle
place à la splendeur à la qualité et à
la bouteille en verre
idéal pour bonifier les vins et offrir
toute leur noblesse des nouveaux vins
qui font une entrée retentissante à la
cour de louis 15 on se déplace même de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique pour
déguster et élire ses vins bordelais
préféré en 1787 le futur troisième
président américain thomas jefferson en
visite dans la région tombe
littéralement sous le charme enivrant de
80 château margaux château lafite
château latour et château haut brion
c'était sans le savoir anticiper sur un
classement qui serait établie seulement
en 1855 et qui de nos jours continuent
de faire référence
[Musique]
c'était émouvant parce que j'ai dans mes
mains la lettre du syndic et des
adjoints donc des courtiers de commerce
de la bourse de bordeaux qui répondent à
aux membres de la chambre de commerce
qui l'avait confié l'émission donc la
mission de faire cette classification
sont des documents émouvant puisque
quand même une date du 18 avril 1855
oui cela peut paraître surprenant mais
ce sont bien des courtiers qui ont
observé les prix du marché et classer
les vins par niveau économique sans
aucun critère qualitatif la
classification a été rapidement fait
elle a été fait en l'espace d'une
quinzaine de jours
alors ici vous avez la liste des
premiers crus la liste des deuxième crue
la liste des troisièmes cru et des 4e et
des cinquièmes cru
voilà en tout 61 crues ont été classés
[Musique]
les quatre châteaux classés premiers
sons lafite margaux latour et haut-brion
haut brion un vignoble connu pour être
l'un des plus anciens de la région
bordelaise
de par ce classement il est aussi l'un
des plus prestigieux
aux côtés de son actuel propriétaire le
prince robert de luxembourg
nous avons découvert les secrets de sa
longévité aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
haut-brion et le vignoble plus anciens
de la région pense qu'il ya eu des
vignes ici planté entre 40 et 60 après
jésus-christ et il ya beaucoup de
familles qui se sont suivies bien celle
qui a le plus marqué l'histoire du
brillant rue clairement c'est des pentes
à pontacq
un nom qui va marquer l'histoire des
plus grands vins de bordeaux
à commencer par son domaine bien sûr
à la fin du xviie siècle à une époque où
tant de guerres font rage
il faut pouvoir stocker le vin arnaud 3
de pontacq fait alors la synthèse de
différentes techniques et invente ce que
l'on appelle aujourd'hui les vins de
garde
avant cela il va s'appeler les classes
l'éclairer qui étaient plus des va du
style que nous avons d'ailleurs toujours
ici à bordeaux aujourd'hui c'était une
façon je pense de protéger le vin est
aussi de mettre l'accent sur des 25 les
mains de briand qui était vraiment
marqué par une qualité à part à titre
exceptionnel le prince robert de
luxembourg nous a autorisés à découvrir
cette technique toujours utilisé trois
siècles plus tard dans le chai du
château haut brion
la première d'entre elles le brûlage du
soufre pour assainir les barriques
puis le soutirage qui en transvasant le
vin le débarrasse de ses impuretés
enfin luyas qui consiste à compenser
l'évaporation en remplissant constamment
les barriques pour éviter que le vin ne
s'oxyde
[Musique]
ce quart no 3 de pontacq invente ce sont
tout simplement les vendent aujourd'hui
son fils innovera son tour en inventant
le concept de châteaux viticoles pour la
première fois un vin porte le nom d'un
terroir dans les restaurants dans les
commerces
on parle désormais de château haut brion
au brillant part cela est peut-être la
première marque de luxe du monde
la notoriété internationale du père des
premiers crus classés est enclenché et
perdure trois siècles plus tard certains
millésime de château haut-brion peuvent
aujourd'hui s'échanger à près de 3000
euros
[Musique]
ils sentent de lettres classiques
j'avais fait sciences po en économie et
finance
j'avais une petite justification mais je
n'y connaissais rien aux vins c'est que
je ne suis pas rendu compte de l'enjeu
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris à bras le
corps ça serait à refaire aujourd'hui
j'aurais peut-être plus de deux reculs
ou ou d'hésitation c'est difficile à
savoir
son investissement corinne le tient de
son père andré menzel aux poules aux
riches entrepreneurs grecs qui en 1977
acquiert un château et des vignes
délaissés dont à l'époque personne ne
veut
première ambition rendre à la baptise
son lustre d'antan dans le plus pur
respect des techniques traditionnelles
ils ont su choisir un architecte des
monuments historiques assez doué connu
mais surtout très amoureux des vieilles
pierres
le résultat est à la hauteur des travaux
engagés aujourd'hui le château de style
néoclassique et compte
qui sait pas d'améliorer il s'agissait
de remettre margot à son niveau qu'il
avait perdue à cause des grands
millésimes et du manque
d'investissements héritière et véritable
ambassadrice du château margaux corinne
menzel au boulot ce porte ces crues de
légende jusqu'aux plus grandes tables de
la planète
vous êtes au service de château margaux
c'est pas château margaux qui vous rend
service ou qui sait c'est nous qui
sommes obligés d'être dans sa longue
histoire une un petit bout finalement
nous passons par hasard et si je peux
dire au moment de partir j'espère le
plus tard possible que je n'ai pas
failli à cette tâche peut en tout cas je
ne vais pas abîmer parce que l'améliorer
est-ce qu'on peut encore que je ne sais
pas
un passage éphémère pour rendre un vin
éternelle le défi quotidien de corinne
menzel au boulot c'est colossal
pour mener à bien cette tâche corinne
s'entoure d'une équipe de véritables
passionnés depuis quatre ans maintenant
jonathan ribera et le tonnelier maison
au plus tôt au château à 38 ans il est
l'un des derniers tonnelier a travaillé
au sein même d'un château viticole
quand j'avais 17 ans j'ai mis les pieds
dans une tonnellerie et j'ai pu lui en
repartir on devient tonnelier part par
amour du métier on ne devient pas tous
nié par hasard ici j'ai la chance de
pouvoir travailler les barriques
quasiment comme cela se faisait il ya
220 ici c'est comme une chance pour la
colonie française de pouvoir conserver
un métier total martin à même de
conserver les valeurs de ce métier là
est toute la technique qui va avec
son atelier est un endroit un peu hors
du temps avec ses odeurs suranné et ses
outils d'autrefois
la première étape est de sélectionner et
d'installer une planche qui va
déterminer la mesure exacte de la
barrique donc tout le travail va être de
déterminer l'emplacement exact des bouts
elle les duels et en des planches de
chêne qui ont été asséchées et entre 24
et 36 mois son bois jonathan le connaît
sous toutes ses rainures une certaine
sensualité entre le tonnelier le bois
qui travaillent le contact du bois y est
et très douce est une matière noble de
s'imaginer que ce bois là est peut-être
bicentenaire
les duels posée jonathan les rassemblent
dans des cercles de montage en véritable
homme orchestre
il prépare alors à l'aide d'une chasse
et d'un marteau
ce qu'on appelle une rose met tout son
savoir faire
jonathan va l'exprimer dans une
prochaine étape nécessaire pour la
qualité du vin la chauffe
j'ai préparé mon brasero de manière à
chauffer la battre la chauffe est le
moment le plus important de la
réalisation d'une barrique
c'est la chose qui va révéler l'état n'a
en 10 duels du bois et suivant
l'intensité de chf
on va obtenir un impact différent sur le
vin qui sera dedans tonnelier ou quand
travailler le bois devient travail et le
vin
je réalise le chauffe qui étaient
déterminés par le maître de chai par
rapport au travail qui veut réaliser sur
les peut obtenir des odeurs de moka de
couper y avoir des goûts toaster
m'échauffer légère trame et des choses
beaucoup plus douze couples feutré des
odeurs de pain grillé donc à l'aide de
capestang qui est qui au sol
je vais resserrer la barrique offert
mesure de sa montée en température après
1h15 de chauffe
jonathan devra rendre l'étanchéité du
fus en lui apposant ses fonds
[Musique]
en une journée il réussir à fabriquer
deux barriques protecteur de cette
tradition jonathan espère bien son tour
transmettre ce savoir faire séculaire et
contribuer ainsi au prestige de château
margaux
[Musique]
bonjour sandrine bonjour sophy
l'impression de vous déranger nos ratios
très particulière je suis concentré je
mes voisins à sandrine garbaye vous êtes
maître de chai ici à château d'yquem et
là c'est in
une opération de surveillance de
contrôle confie-t-il tout à fait nous
sommes ici dans le chai souterrain où
nous avons le millésime 2015 qui est en
élevage et donc je suis en train en fait
de contrôler chaque barrique pour
vérifier que tout va bien que l'élevage
se passe bien
alors est ce que là tout va bien tout va
mourir de la couleur je regarde la
couleur en fait l'aspect il faut
évidemment que le vin soit limpide et
calme donc sans son pétillement aucun
évidemment et le nez doit être
aromatique intense très fruité vraiment
sur un fruit pur et net
ce qui est le cas ici sur ce 2015
tu peux plus
ce travail à cette tradition et étaient
récompensés dès 1855 par le classement
de napoléon iii
yquem devient alors le premier et unique
vin blanc à être classé 1er cru
supérieur
yquem côtoie alors ses illustres voisins
du médoc
[Musique]
notre chasse au trésor dans le vignoble
bordelais se poursuit avec en guise de
carte routière de luxe
ce fameux classement de 1855 après
haut-brion et margot nous nous sommes
arrêtés un instant dans les trois autres
premiers grands crus classés de bordeaux
château latour et son vignoble de 750
mille pieds au bord de la gironde
pour
château lafite rothschild dont le
château du 16e siècle et classée
monument historique
[Musique]
et puis mouton rothschild seul château
ayant intégré le haut du classement
après 1855
mais comme souvent dans les trajets ce
sont les détours les petits imprévus qui
offre des souvenirs impérissables non
classés en 1855 et pour cause il n'est
pas situé en médoc mais à pomerol
courtisé vénéré même il est l'un des
porte étendards de ce que la france
offre de plus raffiné à l'étranger
fermée aux visites jamais exposé aux
caméras de télévision son domaine nous a
été exceptionnellement ouverts pétrus
[Musique]
cet olivier berrouet son tout jeune
directeur qui détient les clés de ce
très discret paradis dont la boisson
divine a fasciné tous ceux qui ont eu le
privilège de la déguster
alors petrus c'est une histoire à la
fois mythique et très récente puisque la
propriété a réellement explosé il ya une
cinquantaine soixantaine d'années d'un
point de vue reconnaissance à la fois
international et puis et puis française
il ya deux événements qui ont qui ont
aidé à la renommée de petrus tout
d'abord le couronnement de la reine
d'angleterre ou des pétrus 47 ont été
servis et l'autre événement aux états
unis petrus est devenu le vin favori
delà de la famille kennedy et notamment
de jeff keay qui a été un ambassadeur de
rêve pour pau pour les vins delà de la
propriété une histoire récente donc qui
est l'oeuvre d'une femme madame loubat
propriétaire de petrus au début du 20e
siècle et de son partenaire jean pierre
moure ex
ils sont les premiers à avoir décelé le
trésor qui était sous leurs yeux ou
plutôt sous leurs pieds
la grande richesse de petrus et c'est
cette terre très argileuse qui a à peu
près 40 millions d'années qui datent
donc de l'ère tertiaire ce sont donc des
alluvions argileuse qui sont
relativement rares à bordeaux puisqu'il
ya 120 mille hectares de vignes à
bordeaux il ya moins de 200 hectares qui
sont exploités sur argile
pétrus c'est en quelque sorte une
exception dans l'exceptionnel alors
forcément olivier porte une attention
toute particulière à ce vignoble d'à
peine plus de 11 hectares ces grands
terroirs il faut pas les brutaliser il
faut les travailler avec beaucoup de
douceur il faut essayer de les
comprendre ça prend ça prend beaucoup de
temps donc un travail mécanique du sol
qui est réalisé pour permettre à ces
argiles b de respirer de permettre aux
racines de s'installer bien en
profondeur ces argiles qui assure un
drainage unique de l'eau sont entretenus
choyé même jour après jour par olivier
ses équipes
donc on a la chance d'avoir des hommes
qui travaillent sur la propriété depuis
un nombre important d'années et qui
savent comprendre qu'ils savent à quel
moment
intervenir sert à toi y'a pas de mal a
dit rien du tout et russes c'est donc
l'histoire d'un sol exceptionnel
insolent mais pas seulement
[Musique]
l'homme que rejoint olivier c'est son
père jean-claude oenologue chez petrus
pendant 44 ans à la retraite depuis 2008
il reste néanmoins le mentor et le
conseiller éclairé d'olivier chaque fois
que olivier bleus au pays des de son
vieux père lui sont utiles aux jeux je
vienne quelle nature sont c'est vraiment
une
un échange que l'on a en permanence donc
lui grâce à son demi siècle d'expérience
sur la sur la propriété donc moi ça son
expérience nourrie mais mes réflexions
pour être toujours faire faire faire
progresser le vignoble le vin est
toujours aller vers une qualité et une
recherche de qualité permanente
vous savez un cru c'est une identité
c'est une personnalité c'est une
typicité et chaque crue est unique
donc tout l'art des responsables c'est
de protéger et de faire exprimer cette
identité cette originalité
pétrus c'est une rencontre entre cette
page le merlot et insolent l'argile qui
est quand même unique
en tous les cas à bordeaux
sa qualité remarquable et remarquée dans
le monde entier
pétrus la doit peut-être aussi à la
valeur des hommes qui la façonnent
d'abord il faut être modeste être humble
être curieux très observateur m d'une
vente de sensibilité également pour bien
pour bien décoder pour bien
diagnostiquer la matière première
moi j'ai baigné dans mon éducation
familiale dans notre sensibilité
je pense que finalement c'est la qualité
la plus importante que j'ai peut-être
transmis à mes fils
[Musique]
aux côtés de la famille - ex
propriétaire de petrus les berrouet père
et fils veille sur un domaine à la
réussite discrète et aux 13 ans
silencieux là on a la chance de
travailler sur un lieu qui est mythique
avec un produit qui est qui absolument
extraordinaire et qui nous procure un
plaisir des sensations des émotions
immense et on met ce temps là dans une
bouteille on sait qu'elle sera partagée
à 10 km 10 600 km 10000 20000 km d'ici
des personnes vont partager ce moment de
plaisir avec leurs amis leur famille et
on met du bonheur de la joie en
bouteille quelque part
ce jour là aux côtés d'olivier nous
avons partagé bien plus qu'un hectare
c'est l'âme de petrus que nous avons
caresser
[Musique]
bonjour pierre mentale et vous ça va
bien pierre lurton donc président
directeur général de château d'yquem
vous avez une sacrée responsabilité si
je dit de vous que vous êtes un peu un
chef d'orchestre est ce que ça veut ça
me va bien parce que les instruments
sont de grande qualité
alors il fallait vraiment un bel écrin
pour les magnifiques nectar que vous
produisez ici il y a un patrimoine bâti
exceptionnel et on le voit bien là ici
dans cette cour
le château a une histoire passionnante à
un château du lac principal parti du
xviie les murs autour sont du 15e et là
vous avez un magnifique chez de le vieux
millésimes d'yquem qui se trouve là et
une maison qui nous permet de recevoir
le monde entier est déjà dans l'histoire
thomas jefferson dans les années 1780
était venu ici et avait trouvé le lieu
magique et le vin incroyable et on avait
acheté 300 bouteilles et vous voyez on
est vraiment dans l'histoire avec m et
on traverse le temps et à ce que côté
intemporel de ce lieu d'excellence que
j'ai la chance de pouvoir partager avec
une équipe merveilleuse
si vous deviez me parler des trois
grands millésimes d'yquem vous
choisiriez lesquels il ya le musée me 67
37 21
il ya les millésimes 293 vendanger le 31
août les plus grands millésimes ils sont
à venir
un but bien sûr
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ces millésimes de légende
sont quasiment introuvables dans le
commerce alors pour les collectionneurs
et les amateurs le seul moyen de s'en
procurer de fréquenter les salles de
vente aux enchères des salles de ventes
qui se transforment parfois en salle aux
trésors
[Musique]
à plus de 600 kilomètres du château
d'yquem dans des hangars de la banlieue
parisienne
près de 3000 bouteilles de vin
d'exception attendent de trouver leur
nouveau propriétaire
ça c'est la fille de 70 château qui n 99
en magnum château de latour 1955 le s80
diète
alors là c'est le grand blanc de la
bourgogne un morceau perrière 90 des
conques la faune ariane brissart est la
responsable du département vin et
spiritueux de l'étude d'agents à paris
ce matin là elle vérifie une dernière
fois l'état des 500 lots qu'elle
proposera aux enchères cet après midi à
des amateurs venus des quatre coins de
la planète
tu es aussi importante on a près de
taye en caisse bois d'origine il ya
douze millésime qui suivent
ariane doit transférer jusqu'à l'étude
l'un de ces trésors conservés dans son
écrin une caisse du domaine de la
romanée conti millésime 2005
une mission délicate on va mettre les
couvertures pour bien les calais et
surtout on sangles pour pas que ça bouge
pendant le transport et moi les moules
non sportes
[Musique]
trois quarts d'heure plus tard le lot
485 arrive à bon port
[Musique]
alors que les premiers acheteurs
prennent place dans la salle ariane et
son équipe
vérifie les derniers ordres d'achat
passé par téléphone ou internet
il est 14 heures la vente démarre du
poids vous souhaiter la bienvenue pour
cette vente consacrée aux grands vins et
spiritueux la vente a été préparé par
ariane briffard et les premiers coups de
marteau du commissaire priseur résonne
dans la salle
âgé de 160 à 250
cette jeune femme c'est pauline à popova
d'origine russe cette grande amatrice de
vins français espère remporter pour un
de ses clients une de ses fameuses
caisses du domaine de la romanée conti
13 bouteilles par caisse estimé entre 12
et 20 mille euros 29 ans
les enchères s'envolent
pernod notre lot 485 exposés dans la
salle atteint des sommets en ville 31ème
30 à 1500 euros adjugée 30 à 1500 euros
téléphone il est 19h et la vente se
termine
ariane a de quoi avoir le sourire les
douze caisses du domaine de la romanée
conti ont trouvé leur nouveau
propriétaire et vont bientôt voyager à
hong kong
los angeles ou encore moscou c'est
vraiment un des joyaux des vins français
et parce que c'est ce terroir qui est
microscopique et on fait des grands vins
sur des grands terroirs et la chance
qu'à la romanée conti
c'est un terroir exceptionnel et pauline
à paulina aussi a le sourire
le lot 485 lui a échappé mais elle a
obtenu une caisse de 2007 un peu plus de
25000 euros
paulina repartira en russie avec bien
plus que des bouteilles en fait c'est
pas que l'étiquette cpq gros château en
fête
derrière c'est l'histoire c'est le sol
c'est
c'est le tiroir c'est tout ce qui est
autour de 20 j'organise de temps en
temps les voyages gastronomiques pour
les clients si particulier et justement
quand elle arrive en france
d'abord c'est il faut goûter le vent il
faut goûter le vent il faut un goûter le
fromage je pense que c'est vraiment
c'est qu'on sait qu'on la tour eiffel en
fait
mais pourquoi pauline avoue-t-elle une
passion un amour immodéré pour ses vins
de bourgogne
nous avons pris une dernière fois la
route pour dénicher ces trésors qui en
russie et ailleurs font la grandeur de
la france
direction le sud de dijon et les grands
crus de la côte de nuits un vignoble aux
identités multiples au rendement modeste
producteurs donc des vins les plus chers
au monde
au beau milieu des vignes nous avons
rencontré vincent barbier le grand
maître de la confrérie des chevaliers du
tastevin chargé de promouvoir et
préserver la culture viticole
bourguignonne je suis né dans le vin est
dans une famille qui était dans la
confrérie du tas de vin mon grand père a
été un des fondateurs
mon père a continué donc je me devais de
continuer notre lieu de rendez vous
vincent lui connaît par coeur
ça a été un terrain de jeu quand j'étais
tout petit et puis aujourd'hui c'est
c'est un instrument extraordinaire c'est
un patrimoine formidable quand je rentre
au château je suis ailleurs jeu je pense
que tout se passe bien je crois que oui
le château est magique le château dont
vincent pas n'est autre que le château
du clos de vougeot
[Musique]
un édifice du 12e siècle construit au
milieu de 50 hectares de vignes
[Musique]
un grand creux que se partagent
aujourd'hui 80 propriétaires
[Musique]
vincent nous emmène découvrir les
trésors de ce symbole quasi millénaire
de l'histoire des vins de bourgogne
voilà nous sommes dans le grand cellier
cisterciens grand cellier du château du
clos de vougeot monument très important
puisque construit au début du 12e siècle
et c'est là que les moines de cîteaux
elle veut conserver leurs vins les plus
précieux on pouvait empirer jusqu'à 2000
tonneaux
ces moines cisterciens ont leur abbaye à
une quinzaine de kilomètres du clos dès
le moyen-âge les ducs de bourgogne leurs
fonds dont de multiples vignes
les moines de cîteaux deviennent alors
de véritables vigneron
ce scellier et est remplacé la caf
puisque nous sommes sur un banc de
roches et les moines avec les techniques
de l'époque n'ont pas pu construire de
calan fait creuser deux cadres ils ont
donc construit ce scellier qui en partie
enterré puisque on voit les vignes à peu
près
et les grands vins de bourgogne puisque
les moineaux
savoir et la durée c'est ça qui est
formidable le savoir parce que il avait
délivré la durée parce que parce que il
plantait un endroit si ça ne marchait
pas il analysait pas la terre il la
goutte m haies mais il faut y voir ce
que ça donnait donc la durée a été
quelque chose de très important puisque
les moines sont restés ici dans ce
château qui l'ont construit pendant plus
de six siècles siècle après siècle les
moines de cîteaux vont organiser et
structurer le vignoble de bourgogne
ils vont alors s'équiper comme en
témoigne en impressionnants vestiges
conservés dans la cuverie du château du
clos de vougeot alors tout à l'heure je
parlais de magie et bien nous y sommes
en plein dans la ma vie puisque nous
sommes devant le pressoir construit en
près de six siècles plus tard ce
pressoir est toujours en activité
c'est des chênes de la forêt de sitôt
qu'ils ont été coupés ils avaient deux
cent cinquante ans ils sont restés
encore 200 ans dans l'eau parce que
c'était le meilleur moyen pour les
garder imputrescible après ils ont séché
ils ont été mis en oeuvre donc on va
dire on la tradition raconte que selon
les chaînes qui ont été plantés
on va dire à l'époque de charlemagne en
l'an 800 c'est une partie de l'histoire
de france bien sûr que cette histoire de
france
les moines de cîteaux vont continuer à
l'écrire en érigeant à côté de l'édifice
du 12e siècle un manoir renaissance
confisquer à la révolution au titre de
bien national le château du clos de
vougeot sera transformé abandonné puis
restauré au gré de ses nouveaux
propriétaires
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce joyau architectural est
le siège de la confrérie des chevaliers
du tastevin près d'une fois par mois
vincent barbier y officier avec son
habit de grands maîtres pour introniser
de nouveaux membres par bacchus dieu du
vin et par saint vincent patron des
vignerons nous armons chevallier du tas
de mots
[Musique]
12000 chevalier au total dont la moitié
d'étrangers tous animés par ce goût pour
un patrimoine unique aux couleurs de la
bourgogne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
unique c'est ce qui caractérise le
domaine le roi à vosne-romanée
si ces vins figurent parmi les plus
recherchés et appréciés au monde ils le
doivent à sa propriétaire un personnage
iconoclaste de 85 ans qui répond au nom
poétique de la lobbies le roi comme est
si jolie mais bon saint gély petits
raisins chasse et la bourgogne
regarde comme il est beau un deux trois
quatre
rezaï et c'est superbe c'est aussi comme
comme une personne vater inter elle vit
elle est bonne elle sent bon mais sentez
vous avez senti très belle lalouette
infatigable quand elle parle de ses
vignes elle en prend soin comme de ses
enfants adeptes de la bio dynamie depuis
la création de son domaine en 1988
lahlou délaisse par exemple la technique
du rognage afin de renforcer l'immunité
de la plante
c'est une viande la vigne est une liane
alors l'apprivoiser d'accord mais l'a
gardé quand même avec d'evry qui sait
qu'ils savent s'accrocher partout et pas
la rogne et les estropiés les petits
raisins sur hbo regarder son joli et ses
petits raisins qui font le meilleur ben
c'est pas les gros raisin on imagine on
perçoit déjà le vin koné sera
lahlou prodigue à sa terre et ses pieds
de vigne des soins dont elle a le secret
aucun pesticide aucun herbicide que des
composts des préparations biodynamique
et des tisanes pulvérisé à même le dos
par de vaillants employés
lahlou nous invite à découvrir une pièce
inhabituel chez un vigneron son officine
derrière et bien sûr toutes mes tisanes
mais des coques surface les plantes
conserve tout au long de l'année
l'origan qui est comme ça chez le futur
petit biotique lorsque deux
antibiotiques ne marcheront plus son
voeu rigan parce que c'est petit c'est
très anti bactérien moi j'en prends tout
le temps si j'ai de l'asthme et j'en
prends tout le temps ça me fait du bien
l'ue reste j'essaie tout sur moi avant
comme ça chez la rhubarbe très très
efficace contre les tout ce qui est
champignons donc les attaques de mildiou
oïdium black rot
c'est extraordinaire romarin quand il
fait froid quelques coups de chaud leur
donne des forces de vie on les empêche
d'être malade et on les renforce et
religieux belle on les jolies et
heureuse voilà on vous le disait lahlou
est un personnage iconoclaste ses
collaborateurs dont frédéric le plus
proches doivent composer avec un
caractère bien trempé c'est mal fagoté
et nouveau m'obliger à tout arranger il
est où le fret et voilà encore conscrits
là parce qu'elle vient qu'à petit à
petit frère fred y avoir il faut plus
même mec que tu viennes m'aider fred
vient voir mais des regards doit sa voix
bien qu'elle elle souffre seulement de
fait les croisés tout ce que j'aime pas
croisé célia t on n'est pas m'emmener
trop loin dans mes vignes parce que je
vais t'en mer 2
nous avons eu nous aussi droit à notre
lot de remarques au bon on y va il soit
ils arrivent à maignon et continue
toujours de pêche
mais à l'image de ses vins lahlou biz le
roi c'est aussi se rendre séduisante et
généreuse mais moi j'ai de la chance que
d'abord j'ai fred qui comprend qu'ils
qui m'aide beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
puis quand même qui avec les gars et
qu'il y ait dans courage quand ça ma foi
ce que bon bah oui quand je suis pas
très patientes n'ont plus foi je vous ai
préparé à bangkok
bokoko 20 et puis on m'a bien mangé j'ai
tout préparé tout est prêt wilfred
nine tu vas pas dans l'eau à l'heure du
déjeuner nous avons donc goûter ce
fameux coq au vin vin du domaine bien
sûr énième moment d'authenticité de la
sauce parce qu'elle est bonne
voyez comment ces deux gros coups sont
permis
[Musique]
cette intimité que nous avons eu le
privilège de partager
nous avons voulu l'aggraver lors d'une
conversation improvisée pour connaître
les motivations de celles que l'on peut
aujourd'hui considérer comme un
véritable trésor vivant bien mobile de
vie venez jozami j'ai été baptisé en fin
d'avant midi un quart d'heure après ma
naissance mon père m'a mis sur les
lèvres bien sûr je m'en rappelle plus
quelques gouttes de mu unis 29 gvt je
suis né dans le vin j'ai 1020 j'ai été
élevé dans le respect du vrai dans
l'amour du vin sans mon père je n'aurais
rien pu faire parce que mon père était
extraordinaire d'abord de me laisser
faire une gamine de 23 ans
lahlou nous confie qu'elle a travaillé
pendant 30 ans aux côtés de ce père
qu'elle vénère négociant en vins et
copropriétaire du domaine de la romanée
conti
jusqu'à ce qu'elle décide de constituer
son propre domaine
ce que je savais c'est que je voulais
produire des vins telles que je les
réveils depuis toujours
tel que je vais chercher tout au long de
ma carrière
vincent reflète son village les
habitants du village le passé du village
et voilà le vin le miroir de leur tout à
fait ça
avec son humilité paysanne la louve is
leur one aimerait certainement pas
contempler ses vins l hiver est pourtant
de véritables chefs-d'oeuvre que le
monde entier brûle de déguster toutes
mes dégustation a toujours été à la
gloire de la bourgogne pas forcément à
la gloire de leroy à la gloire de la
banque est vraiment vraiment ce que
c'est
c'est énorme je me rends bien compte que
c'est énorme comme patrimoine
[Musique]
modeste en superficie ce patrimoine
viticole de bourgogne est effectivement
énorme en prestige et en histoire en
témoignait le château du clos de vougeot
bien sûr
[Musique]
l'abbaye de cîteaux
oh
[Musique]
le palais des ducs de bourgogne à dijon
ou encore les hospices de beaune dont
les illustres vente aux enchères
rassemble les touristes et amateurs de
vins du monde entier
[Musique]
voir mythique château extraordinaire la
main de l'homme a façonné des trésors
inestimables que le monde entier nous
envie
la main de l'homme bien sûr mais aussi
cette terre une terre nourricière qui
ici à château d'yquem comme dans tous
les autres domaines que nous avons eu la
chance de découvrir aujourd'hui est
certainement le trésor le plus précieux
ce patrimoine exceptionnel du vignoble
français nous a été légué il y à des
siècles
il nous appartient donc de le cultiver
de le protéger pour que jamais ne
disparaisse ses trésors
[Musique]
moi